that's about as famous again because
Elvis up was kind of that was an
established you as a I was adult movie
star but that makes it sound wrong I
mean that was kind of your your big
breakout role isn't it it really that
really was I mean but the thing about it
is is that when you're playing the
coca-cola can because everybody knows
what you know it's and you got that way
at the time Sarah Palin was really well
known everybody knew what she looked
like and sounded like it's very
difficult cuz that puts you give the
parameters there that you cannot go
outside of that or you start losing
weight but we I only had to be
two-dimensional you had to portray this
personally I had but I had I had help
with the screenplay on the story sure
you know a lot going for it so all this
thing kind of crops up in your life
because one of your very first acting
roles it was with the real Elvis yeah it
was 62 something like that it was the
World's Fair and I was 10 years old and
I got this job you know to play this kid
that kicks Elvis in the shins to picking
away he wants to meet a girl a nurse so
he figures you know who gets this kid
that injure him a little bit and I kind
of hit him a little too hard and he you
know but he paid me 50 cents and then
later on when she's with him
I run into him at the fair and I say hey
mister gonna kick you in the shin again
look you know he goes get away you can
do for a quarter I'll give me a bigger
quarter I'm did you the monkey walk
do you get that it was Elvis I mean
that's no I was my first brush with
celebrity though I never
I'd never I was just a kid you know yeah
it was great it was really a nice man
and he he came on the set in the car and
there were you know is that the world is
fair was just opening and so there's a
lot of people there and all of a sudden
he came on the set and maybe two or
three thousand women just went cussed
jump the car and bail out and come in a
different way and I thought this guy
must really be famous
[Music]
you